hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about future science and
technology and I see
a bunch of interesting questions here
uh
uh where should we start Omar is asking
what can you say about the future of
physics
well gosh
I'm a funny person to ask that because
last three years we've really done a
bunch of things which I think Define
kind of a very new direction for physics
in terms of its methodology at least
I mean if we look at the history of
physics
they've been
well Antiquity people started talking
about maybe there are definite laws that
govern the world maybe there are
definite regularities to the world maybe
the world is made up of lots of
identical things there's sort of
definite regular things that one can say
about the world then sort of the thing
that launched kind of what became much
of physics as it has been is what
happened in the 1600s first with Galileo
then with Newton and so on which was the
mathematicization physics but one could
take mathematical formulas one could
take algebra and so on
and apply this to physics and then
calculus was invented then that became
sort of the main methodology of physics
is describe the world using mathematical
equations particularly calculus and it
had a great run
I mean what happened at first was
mechanics
there was a lot of developments and
mechanics the the sort of the the big
problem with the three body problem
things like Earth Moon Sun you know with
gravitational attractions between them
come unsolved for their motions and that
was finally done respectively much by
the beginning of the 20th century but it
took a while after Newton's 1687 you
know principia with his universal law of
gravitation and so on it took a while
for those formulas to actually sort of
get worked out
but then
after that came lots of other physics
whether that was the physics of um
uh fluids fluid dynamics equations of
fluid mechanics the equations of solid
mechanics equations of electromagnetism
lots of equations for things got
developed and then when quantum
mechanics started in the 1920s again it
was a story of equations the Schrodinger
equation the Dirac equation the uh
equations for describing things
and um uh that that's kind of been the
dominant Paradigm is this kind of
mathematical equations type Paradigm now
there were some things that didn't quite
fit that I mean for example in the
development of statistical mechanics in
the development of trying to understand
thermodynamics trying to understand the
second world autonomics those were
things that were happening in the 1860s
and so on and they were not so much kind
of let's just write down an equation
people certainly tried to do that they
didn't succeed in deriving the second
order of the Dynamics in a sort of
equational type way
and actually then I suppose a different
tradition of of physics emerged
that had kind of had a precursor in the
psychologics because when people like
Ludwig boltzmann were trying to prove
the second row of the Dynamics the thing
that he realized one had to do is to
start thinking in terms of discrete
atoms nobody knew discrete atoms existed
but to think about kind of the formal
structure that you get if discrete items
existed and you're starting to count
things combinatorially you're starting
to be able to make very different kinds
of arguments from the kinds of arguments
that have been made on the basis of
algebra and calculus and so on
previously in physics
and those arguments were things about
well we have this whole collection of
different possible States and there's a
certain kind of Randomness and we take
averages and things like this and that
was kind of a new way of of thinking
about physics more in a sense a way that
went back to kind of philosophical
traditions of kind of let's just figure
it out rather than uh as leibniz would
say calculamus let us calculate by which
he meant you know do algebra and
calculus and so on
and uh they so then
that tradition
the the kind of the big prize was can
you prove the second row of the Dynamics
from
uh from Pure mechanics from just knowing
the Dynamics of individual molecules
bouncing around can you prove that in
the aggregate entropy will tend to
increase that that things will tend to
get more random Etc et cetera et cetera
that was attempted for uh the latter
half of the of the 19th century uh and
failed
and one of the the later people who
tried to do it was a certain Albert
Einstein who starting in about 1903 uh
wrote a series of papers trying to prove
the secondary of Dynamics using
arguments that were in a sense kind of
sort of philosophical logical arguments
if you have a box that is connect that
has this temperature and it's connected
to one with this temperature and they
come to equilibrium and they do this and
this and this then it must follow sort
of logically that the second world of
thermodynamics is is correct
okay he never succeeded at that in fact
what he did was kind of a bit bit off
track
then in 1905 he kind of took the same
methodology of just let's set down
essentially some axioms for how the
world must work and work out their
logical consequences and let's see where
that takes us and so the first place it
took him was special activity which was
a story of you know as soon as the
writer's constant assume that things
appear the same in all states of motion
then logically we can deduce that there
will be time dilation Etc et cetera et
cetera so big big win there similar
thing with Brownian motion uh analyzing
kind of what the the kind of dynamics of
of sort of random motion of Articles and
Iran and what would be and then somewhat
similarly with the idea of photons and
the kind of taking seriously the
quantization of the electromagnetic
field
again sort of an argument by this is the
way things have to be with in that case
a certain amount of mathematics
stressing it up so to speak but this
idea that you could sort of figure
things out from this in the structural
way which had emerged from the work in
in working on the second row of
thermodynamics in the 19th century with
popular like boltzmann kind of
translated into that okay so there was
this big burst of interest in activity
in physics
starting uh in the beginning of the 20th
century and another piece of that same
kind of story was was Einstein's 1915
general relativity
and then in the 1920s uh sort of lots of
development of the idea of quantum
mechanics
um in a fairly traditional mathematical
framework
so that led to in the 20th century three
big ideas in physics statistical
mechanics of which the the core is the
second order of thermodynamics uh
General activity theory of gravity and
mechanics and uh uh quantum mechanics
and later Quantum field Theory the uh
the theory of how things on the very
small kind of work
so those have been the three dominant
theories across the last century and a
certain amount of development has been
done they those theories have been
extremely successful
and uh it's been something where but
it's you know reconciling those theories
a little bit complicated and
particularly between general relativity
and quantum mechanics been challenging
to kind of fit those two theories
together
the thing that got really exciting was
our physics project which kind of got
launched in 2020 where we really can
understand kind of how all three of
these big theories of 20th century
physics how they fit together and
actually in the end they are in some
sense the same Theory they all work the
same way they all are a result of the
interplay between underlying
computational sophistication of the
processes going on in the world and our
computational limitations as observers
of those processes
so for me it's it's kind of a really
exciting sort of convergence that these
three things which where we thought well
statistical mechanics might be derivable
but General artillery we didn't imagine
that was derivable from anything sort of
more fundamental and similarly quantum
mechanics and now what we realize is
they're all sort of equally derivable
from in the end sort of necessary
features of of formalism
so okay so what does that mean well it's
a tremendously fertile moment because it
means we've got a new methodology and in
a sense the core of that methodology is
just the description of everything in
computational terms what is space it's
not some mathematical thing where we
have some manifold that we described
with mathematics and calculus it's this
typograph this thing made of atoms of
space where in principle we could just
say it's this particular hypograph and
uh well not quite this particular one
because it ends up being a multi-way
system
Etc et cetera et cetera but but roughly
you could sort of you know conceptually
pick it up and and grab onto it
um it's a it's a thing where in the end
everything is represented
computationally we can run simulations
little simulations where we can actually
they're big enough that we can see black
holes and dynamics of black holes things
like that but they're still very small
compared to sort of our everyday
experience of the world
but so it's it's a fantastically it's
just great it's it's it's uh you know
there was a as I say there have been a
couple of big advances and sort of the
the paradigms for physics one late 1600s
kind of the introduction of mathematics
Center physics to kind of the uh uh the
early 20th century this kind of um
introduction of kind of this this almost
logical way of thinking about
um physics and how things and physics
get put together uh which I think
Einstein was was a key uh sort of
contributor and and now we have another
one
um and uh in which we're kind of
thinking about physics in in
fundamentally computational terms and
that doesn't mean taking the existing
equations of physics and putting on a
computer something people do with with
our technology with mathematical
language and so on all the time
um I'm talking about thinking about
physics in a fundamentally a
computational way where the actual
mechanics of the universe is
computational processes sort of all the
way up and down
and what's going to happen from that
well you know we're we're just at the
point it's it's a difficult thing to
actually work through the formal
consequences of it involves the sort of
very upper reaches of abstract
mathematics it involves
well a lot of kind of practical computer
simulation it involves a bunch of new
figuring out like you know we've got
calculus and we've got you know one
variable calculus and multivariable
calculus but it's integer numbers of
variables we need the generalization of
calculus to fractional dimensional space
for example something which just not
been worked out in the history of
mathematics and we have to work it out
to be able to understand the
consequences of these models so it's
it's a thing where uh that's sort of the
direction now you know what is happening
in more detail there's one is kind of
really developing the formalism that's a
story of pretty much all the different
methods of mathematical physics that
have been developed plug into the sort
of foundational approach that we're
taking whether that is you know String
Theory or or causal set theory or or all
sorts of other kinds of approaches the
mathematical physics that have been
taken
um unless those approaches are really
completely off track and most of them
are not they are they plug in as some
kind of limit of what we're doing and
understanding that is an important
Direction and I think then the uh the
thing that um
uh we can then do is is say well okay
what are the consequences of this model
how does it what kinds of predictions
does it make what kinds of things does
it manage to say the world must be this
way it must have an electron a mule on a
towel laptop we don't know that yet but
to be able to show from this underlying
model what its consequences are and
we're starting to be able to see a big
Frontier that I'd like to find more
people to help with actually is um sort
of understanding the sort of everyday
astrophysics condensed matter physics
consequences of our models of physics
what does the dimension fluctuation look
like to a Space Telescope what is the
consequence in a black hole merger of
the discreetness of space these kinds of
things we're starting to get some idea
of that but that's a lot of hard work of
physics to to do those things once once
we are at a point where we really know
what the Space Telescope should see or
what this experiment should observe
they seem to be a rather nicely a a very
good collection of
experimentalists who are interested in
in exploring these things actually going
to look for these effects but we don't
really know what the effects that will
be observable as opposed to very low
level things in the model
um what those are like so there are a
lot of a lot of directions there and you
know a lot of things that have been
thought about in physics and where
people got really stuck understanding
kind of quantum gravity and things like
this
it's clear we have a definite path
forward
um the actual going forward of that path
is difficult it's both sort of
mathematically formally difficult it's
computationally difficult it's difficult
to give the interpretations and so on
but there is at least a path which is
something we haven't had for for a very
long time in physics so that's sort of a
exciting thing that I think will will a
lot a lot of stuff is going to fall into
place a lot of things about the universe
that have seemed kind of random like we
don't know why it is that way I think we
will understand why it is that way why
it has to be that way and in particular
the kind of the structure of the theory
will end up being four observers like us
the universe that we observe must look
this way
Observer is very different from us will
observe a different Universe even though
at a sort of formal underlying level of
the level of this thing we call a
rouliad it's all the same but the slice
that is taken by different kinds of
observers is different
and so really the question is it's a
kind of an introspective question in
many ways what features of us as
observers are there so for example one
thing I've been thinking about recently
I haven't don't have good things to say
about yet what if we could think a
million times faster than we do you know
our cycle time of our neurons is maybe a
millisecond uh typical computer it's a
it's um uh a nanosecond more like
um and you know what if we could think a
million times faster what would the
world look like you know a million times
faster the speed of light uh propagate
you know delays are significant even
looking around this room you know it's
uh light only goes a foot in a
nanosecond and so you know one would see
sort of strobing a rival of photons and
so on one would have a different view of
what is going on in the world
and so it's kind of an interesting
question what laws of physics would be
useful to a thing that thinks a million
times faster than we do what laws of
physics will be useful to something
which exists on a scale the scale of a
proton for example uh or the scale of a
galaxy there are different laws of
physics would be useful to describe the
kinds of things one observes there and
and so that's a sort of a and then what
I think we're going to discover is that
the laws of physics says we have them
and the kinds of descriptive parameters
that we use depend on sort of a great
detail of us as Observer it's kind of
like you could say well you know the
universe we observe is one where it
depends on the fact that we are sitting
on this particular planet in this
particular solar system in this
particular Galaxy were we to be somebody
somewhere else we would have a different
observation and experience of the
universe but we happen to be here and so
it is with what we call rulial space and
so it is with what we call Branch Hill
space these are both more abstract kinds
of spaces that we happen to exist in a
particular place in those spaces and so
we observe things the way we observe
them and and that's uh I think that's
sort of an important part of of
understanding it's sort of this
introspection part of our understanding
how one could reduce things about
physics
but you know what consequences does all
this have well for fundamental physics I
think it has dramatic consequences uh
about understanding the way the way
things uh are put together I think the
methods that we've developed that are
these what we call multi-computational
methods are also applicable to a lot of
things that are about more practical
kinds of physics and the application the
interplay between physics and
Mathematics physics and economics
physics and molecular biology all these
kinds of things we now have a new kind
of methodology that in a sense we can
anchor to the things that we've learned
in physics so far and apply to other
fields so that's another kind of
direction there's a close interplay for
example between distributed computing
I'm just about to actually post
something about about that very topic
and these ideas and fundamental physics
um but uh
you know what's the future of physics I
think that you know we now have a new
form of of sort of uh way to construct
physical theories and I think there will
be new kinds of questions that can be
asked I don't know so much what those
are yet
um I know more the kind of the way in
which one can reconstruct what's already
known about physics from something more
for a lower level
I think
when it comes to what
kinds of physics experiments
will be doable I mean a lot of the
advance of physics
has come both from these paradigmatic
advances and from advances in
instrumentation of you know now there
are electronic amplifiers so we can do
this or that
um now there are particle accelerators
so we can do this or that
um I think it's an interesting question
as we have these different methodologies
and paradigms for thinking about physics
what new kinds of experiments will
become possible right now there's not a
huge amount that's super exciting I
think on the horizon in terms of of
qualitatively different kinds of
experiments and we will we can build
bigger particle accelerators I'm not
sure that that's the right way to to do
sort of that Frontier whether it's like
a smaller number of particles to a
higher energy rather than just a
um uh sort of continuing the direction
we have I'm not sure I think in Quantum
Mechanics for example I think that the
sort of a big effort that's been spent
on computing has I mean I don't think
it's going to be successful from the
point of view of practical practical
delivery of something truly Quantum
branded I think it'll be successful as a
way to make computers out of physical
devices other than semiconductors and
also the formalism of quantum Computing
is very interesting and has lots of lots
of mileage and plugs in very nicely with
our our models
um but I think there are questions about
whether there are different kinds of
experiments that become possible when
you're dealing with very large numbers
of atoms and so on that we don't yet
know how to do and maybe we will learn
how to do that when we understand
distributed computing better and sort of
there'll be a this way of a little bit
of a choice you can either be running
the simulation or the the measurement
inside your computer and in which case
it's not clear you know as you do a
sophisticated measurement it's almost as
if you're doing a piece of simulation as
part of the measurement and then as
compared to what you're actually
observing in the first of a world but
they think there's probably some some
mileage to be gotten in that direction
let's see
uh
gosh
um
Lola is asking something practical do
you think pens and pencils still have
room for improvement or has writing
technology been perfected you know one
thing that frustrates me about about
pens is I like to keep
sort of archives of everything
and
I've sort of been surprised there isn't
a pen with with mems with accelerometers
inside it where it can just record
everything you write you know forget
about actually seeing a piece of paper
it just knows where the pen is and it
can somehow detect that it's on a piece
of paper and writing and then can send
it to your computer I mean there are
things where you can I think there may
be as one device that does something
like that but it's based on sort of
having a uh a pad of with a bunch of of
wires that measure where the pen is
underneath I just want to be able to do
it just from my pen so to speak now you
know you might ask the question uh that
there's sort of this issue of how does
technology advance
given that we humans are not advancing
so to speak we still have our ten
fingers we still have certain things
that we're able to do and other things
we're not able to do one of the
constraints on technology was that you
know you can build and we could build
something that was an interface to some
very sophisticated device that had a
thousand levers and ten thousand buttons
but humans wouldn't be able to use it
and the thing that ends up happening is
that through kind of user interface
design and so on through various kinds
of sort of physical devices we end up
being able to sort of pull into the
domain of human accessibility
uh different kinds of technical
modalities
and so for example a good example of one
that we don't yet have is sort of
molding things in three-dimensional
space you know when you want to specify
a three-dimensional object on a computer
it's kind of a pain it's you know a lot
of detailed stuff you have to give now
you know there have been attempts and
they're not quite there and maybe with
the next generation of augmented reality
it'll finally arrive where you can just
have sort of virtual clay in your hands
and you can just sort of sculpt this
thing and it'll have sort of snap grids
that say oh you're making roughly a
sphere let's you know just do this to
make it exactly a sphere something like
that but that's something where you know
we have an interface modality which is
kind of our fingers moving things around
in space we've got our fingers we can do
what we can do with our fingers that's
so you know how do we connect to the
things that we intrinsically are able to
deal with like moving our fingers around
um so you know when it comes to writing
there's something we're sort of
intrinsically able to do which is move
things around in two Dimensions you know
there's can we write it in 3D you know
there was I think for a while there was
some kind of 3D pen that that people
were talking about
um you know what would that be like is
it useful right now it doesn't seem
terribly useful but but each of these
things needs a certain
kind of the creativity of interface
to be able to make something that really
works well with humans so for example
when smartphones came into existence
there were you know at the beginning
touch screens and so on had existed for
a while there was a lot of kind of janky
stuff and then finally perhaps another
small measure due to Steve Jobs actually
um the uh the the kind of the the sort
of idea that you could really make a
smooth clean interface that was just a
touch screen on a phone-like device
um was uh it was realized and the idea
the crazy idea I think it was Philippe
Khan's idea of uh put a camera into a
phone it's like what a crazy thing to do
but then it turns out that once you do
that there are all kinds of
possibilities because you have a camera
typically with you at all times and Etc
et cetera et cetera
um and and so I think these things about
well what can you do with the humble pen
so to speak well I I think there are you
know depending on what you know there
are all kinds of things that I can
imagine doing from recording everything
you write
um to the 3D pen to uh to all sorts of
things
um
so I think that's uh you know those are
uh most of these
uh I mean the idea of a pen something
you hold in your hand and you sort of
make something uh you know you you are
doing sort of repeatable two-dimensional
uh squiggles or whatever that seems to
be a good sort of human user interface
thing if we were octopuses we might have
a different point of view but you know
we're uh given the way we are there are
certain things that work well now my
guess is that over the course of time we
will discover more things that work well
I mean people didn't know about you know
touch screens with pinch Zoom they
didn't know uh different you know there
are different kinds of things like for
example one the thing that isn't quite
here yet is uh
uh what are they called Electro oh what
is it called the the way that you can
feel a different texture based on
electrical effects on essentially a
touch screen that oh it went you know it
went you know felt like a a rough piece
of rock or it felt like a a piece of
fabric or something
um and you know how useful is that and
there's also things like force feedback
which exists in things like joysticks
and so on there's more kind of you know
as you move your finger it kind of you
kind of feel as if you're hitting the
edge of the screen people have done some
of that
um even though what you're feeling is
just some electrical effect it's not a
physical boundary at all but I think
there are a lot of these things where
there will be sort of more advances in
kind of plugging into the way we humans
are so for example the sense of touch
there's quite a bit with texture that
hasn't really been properly developed I
think will get developed the sense of
three-dimensionality is still kind of
not really well developed as augmented
reality goes further we'll we'll get
more ability to sort of interact with
the three-dimensionality of the world
let's see
Epi is asking should we prioritize
adding new senses to ourselves like a
magnetic sense for example for better
observation of the world I think it'd be
really interesting to routinely have
additional sensors and that will be
possible when we have sort of routinely
have augmented reality when it becomes
fashionable to wear glasses again
because that's where you put your
augmented reality so to speak and uh I
think the you know I think I talked
about it another time that you know when
if you can sort of see in the infrared
and UltraViolets and you're kind of
superimposing some you know flashing
thing on your scene of the world so to
speak
um we'll get intuition I don't have a
tuition for what the the typical scene
I'm in what it's like in the ultraviolet
I don't have intuition for what the you
know when I see something that looks red
I just think it's red I don't think you
know what's its frequency spectrum I
don't know whether it has little
discrete pieces to its frequency
spectrum if I had routinely saw that in
the world I would get intuition about
that and routinely wanted to start to
have words to describe you know things
that are a particular I mean you know
you might say uh that looks like a rough
surface okay that's in the in the visual
in a visual form but you know that looks
like a surface that is hot at one end of
cold at the other and has this
characteristic and that characteristic
we don't have of simple words for those
kinds of things because they're not part
of our everyday experience but if they
became part of our everyday experience
we get lots of other sort of
descriptions and we might end up
realizing that there are things that are
kind of worth describing uh sort of
scientifically that we haven't been been
paying attention
um uh with that I think people are
asking her about um direct neural
connections and yes that's obviously I
think I've talked about that several
times before
um you know that's that's another form
of user interface and figuring out kind
of what it feels like to have a direct
neural connection just like as you kind
of uh uh as you if you uh you know it's
kind of like if you've been uh sort of
blind for a while and now you get sight
again what is it like to start to see
again and so on and that's kind of what
one expects it to be like when one can
have sort of a more direct connection
there'll be a lot that we certain amount
that the the connector can learn and a
certain amount our brains can learn
about how to achieve things from that
um
let's see
Okay C asks when will it become
mainstream a mainstream view that
mathematics is merely a branch or form
of computational work and as such sort
of a physical science
you know every field of human endeavor
develops certain methodology and that
methodology comes to define the field
and when a radically new methodology is
invented
often the field with its name and so on
will right off into the sunset and kind
of go extinct and something new will
come in its place
so for example when computer science as
we now call it was starting to develop
ideas about computers and programming of
computers and so on starting to develop
much of what was done were sort of two
branches there was the electrical
engineering Branch maybe three branches
the electrical engineering Branch the
mathematics branch and the kind of
Business Systems data collection type of
branch
and I think the fact that
the methodology of mathematics could
have developed in the direction of being
sort of deeply computational but it
didn't and Mathematics stayed as it was
and continues to sort of Move Along
but computer science and the theoretical
aspect so that really broke off as a
separate discipline with a different
name and so on and so for mathematics
one of the things about mathematics is
that it is done as a as a constructive
theoretical discipline where you're sort
of trying to say let me imagine a
theorem let me create a proof and those
kinds of things
it's not an empirical science for
example in most of the way that people
claim it's practiced you know physics
some part of physics has to do with
looking at the actual natural world and
seeing what it's like I have to say that
our own efforts in kind of seeing the
consequences of the rouliad and so on
are less of that kind they're more this
is the foundation and now the difficulty
is to understand what the consequence of
that Foundation is
some of the way one does that is through
computer experiment but that's different
from experiment looking at the the
natural world as it is although in the
end I think they will turn out to be the
same because the natural world is
ultimately computational but in
mathematics people have it's been a very
funny thing because the methodology of
mathematics doesn't say oh in your paper
you write about how I did this
experiment now in your paper you write
I invented this theorem from who knows
where I pulled it out of the air and now
I have this proof that you can
understand that I've written down now
the fact is an awful lot of particularly
the world's sort of top mathematicians
over the course of history have been in
the back room so to speak doing
experiments these days using Mathematica
in the past using pencil and paper these
kinds of things they do experiments they
um
and they come up with empirical
conclusions and then they say now I've
guessed what the theorem is let me go
try and prove the theorem and then I'll
just write down the theorem and I'll not
show anybody those experiments which
were kind of messy and uh you know just
indicative and they weren't they weren't
the true mathematics they were just a
way of helping you develop my intuition
that's the way people talk about
mathematics today I don't think that's
the right way to do it I think there's
an awful lot that is possible by
studying empirically this sort of
computational mathematical universe and
that's a valid field in its own right
just as most fields of science for
example the experimental part of the
field is much bigger than the
theoretical part of the field in biology
there's practically no theoretical part
it's all experiment and physics is a bit
more matched
um but uh you know I think that that's a
big piece of the story of the future of
mathematics now there are different
vectors leading to that kind of thing
there's the whole sort of tradition of
automated theorem proving proof
assistance
um those are still not at all they're
not absorbed into into mainstream
mathematics because they are uh kind of
methodologically very different from
mathematics I mean doing sort of the
Aesthetics of mathematics the Elegance
of the proof and so on it's like who
cares if it's automated they're
improving and there's just a you know a
grindy machine that's going and saying
yes I can in principle prove it it's
true but you humans don't even want to
look at the proof because it's way too
messy
so let's see
um
Harry comets
I like the thought that there are kids
now playing four-dimensional multiplayer
games where the next generation won't
even be able to understand the trivial
stuff we were thinking about I have to
say with with computer games and so on
and probably a good data point
for somebody who is incapable of
understanding sophisticated modern games
because I really haven't ever played
video games and as they have advanced
um you know in their sophistication they
become quite incomprehensible in many
cases to me
um so I'm I'm kind of a it's it's an
example and I I'm not saying it from
Pride I'm just saying it from laziness
in a sense that I haven't gone and
explored this domain particularly uh
it's um it's kind of an indication of
what it feels like to be sort of
technologically left behind at least for
me
um that you know I don't understand I
see this stuff it's sort of things are
flashing on the screen and people are
pressing buttons and things are
happening and I don't know what's going
on and I think that that's a sort of a a
little bit of a an indication of you
know you transport yourself to the
Future and then the whole world looks
like that to one and and just like you
know if you're if you've never seen a a
smartphone and you're just sort of
plopped into the into the world with
full of phones
um it's you know it's kind of shocking
what's possible there I think um
um
in uh this whole question about what
what seems obvious now to us and what we
can routinely do and what is there's a
sort of a question of what's learnable
and what's not learnable if you went
back to the 1600s and gave our friends
like leibniz and Newton and so on you
candid them a laptop
what would happen
would they be like just totally confused
or would they be able to learn
reasonably quickly you know give them
Wolfram language you know let's invert
the history of the development of
calculus and let's say the computation
came first we've got you know open
language running it's still able to
compute things and then we're kind of
going back and then what does Isaac
Newton do given given that so to speak
and sort of an interesting question what
is what is readily learnable by people
and what is is difficult to learn what
maybe most impossible to learn I mean we
we know that there are manual tasks and
there are cognitive tasks that humans
just can't really do I mean you you show
somebody some Tangled ball of string
that represents some graph that hasn't
been properly laid out you say lay the
scrap out most people find that super
difficult to do and it's kind of an
ultimate example of kind of men mental
rotation something or other imagining
it's it's hard to do and people find it
hard to do or you give people some
control of the you know like the the uh
the old
um quadricopters of uh you know fly this
drone well it wouldn't be a drone
because you're flying it yourself but
fly this thing with four rotors you know
control it so it doesn't go unstable
nobody could do it
it can now be done by with technology
with microprocessors and so on but that
was not something that humans with oh
you've got these seven levers that
you're pulling people couldn't keep that
in stable flight and so there are things
people just can't do given our current
sort of biological construction and I
think there's sort of the things where
people can learn it over time the things
where people will never be able to do it
and there are things which as soon as
you show it to them it's like oh that's
obvious like I suspect you know pinch
zoom on a smartphone pretty obvious to
most people once you show it to them I
mean there are other things where there
are different kinds of oh you you uh uh
different kinds of things which are not
intuitive once you're shown them
so that's interesting question whether
there are things where they can be
educated to but they are not intuitively
obvious and that's a case where the kids
of today so to speak who have been
educated through that
um can get to it and somebody just being
sort of dropped into it cannot and the
same is absolutely true with with
scientific paradigms with learning you
know computational language and so on
it's you know I I see lots of kids who
are fluent in woven language are very
fluent in it and who can really take you
know the test of fluency in modern
languages can you start typing before
you can explain what you're going to do
and I I certainly can do that and I see
a whole bunch of kids who can do that
and and other people too but but it's an
interesting process and you know one of
the things that we've it's it's sort of
a fascinating thing because you have
with with language you have this kind of
superpower of of of of taking things
that you can formulate computationally
in your mind and getting them
implemented I sort of realized recently
that there's over the course of the last
35 years they're just an amazing number
of kind of intellectual leaders in all
sorts of different fields and
organizations and domains and so on who
use a language
every day very often
um to do things and yet there's a huge
bolus of sort of traditional software
engineering programmers who are like oh
no it's too difficult for me it's it's
uh you know I just write my low-level
code in some in some you know low-level
programming language and I kind of was
was have been confused and I sort of
realized this recently why is it that
sort of the the intellectual leader
crowd so routinely and so
enthusiastically uses our technology and
the kind of rank and file programming
crowd is so uh kind of in a sense
resistant to it and I think the thing I
realized is if your typical programmer
who just sort of shows up to work every
day most of what you do does not involve
conceptualizing sort of what you should
do it mostly involves just you know
write the lines of code Type Thing and
maybe once a month you're like okay now
I have to sort of figure out a bit of a
picture but when you use Wilson language
for example it's all about bigger
picture because we've automated all of
that you know most of that sort of blank
blind grind part of the kind of
programming process and so it's kind of
a thing where where it's kind of a a
daunting effort to some people of sort
of actually thinking
or a very invigorating and energizing
thing for people who routinely can sort
of think computationally about things
and so you know we see people who are
typically kind of intellectual leaders
of some kind or another
um or are becoming so who sort of
routinely are doing the think implement
thing in woven language immediately so
to speak very different from sort of the
the typical I'm just writing a big lump
of code type thing that is happening in
much of the kind of software engineering
world and I think that the uh it's
really quite interesting to see to what
extent how much faster how much more
effective the sort of the people with
the superpower are relative to everybody
else but the superpowers is you know is
is challenging to yield because it it to
to wield because it has you know it you
you have to actually know what direction
to think in so to speak so why am I
saying this I'm saying this partly
because I think that there will be a you
know as more people begin to understand
how to think computationally how to
think in terms of a computational
language how to delegate to a computer
all that stuff that the programmers are
spending all their effort writing then
you know that becomes the possibility of
kind of going much further and that you
know as what I can see from people who
are you know young fluent well from
language programmers so to speak that uh
it's it it must look like magic to many
people in fact I I know people say that
and uh of uh that you know it's like how
can you do that how can you make this
computational thing in a matter of a few
minutes that is sort of singing and
dancing in these ways and so to to the
people who just don't get it don't know
that don't know how to think
computationally about these kinds of
things it's it's going to look like
something Out Of Reach just as and I
think that's that's kind of a a uh uh
you know that that's a that's a major
sort of future Trend I have to say you
know as somebody in the middle of this
whole thing this kind of development of
computational language which I've been
doing now for 40 years
um it is amazing how how slow the
process of seeing these things widely
absorbed is although I mean of course
there are millions of people who use our
attack every day but but there should be
many many more than that and it is also
true that the
the kind of the the Leading Edge so to
speak which is full of people who use
our Tech all the time is is kind of that
the the sort of an interesting
separation and an interesting set of
time scales of what's the diffusion time
from those folk to sort of everybody and
the answer is it's many decades and uh
uh it's kind of uh you know I don't know
how many decades it's always I think
I've said this a bunch of times before
it's much easier for me at least to
predict what will happen than how long
it will take to happen and for me it's
just it's completely inexorable that
sort of computational language it's sort
of the the analog of mathematical
notation for the future and it's the
thing what one thinks in terms of if one
wants to formalize one's thoughts make
them computational and so on that is the
future uh you know some people uh are
sort of living in the future today but
for many people that future is probably
going to be a while away
um so
a few thoughts there
um
Elsie is asking how do you envision
mathematics being practiced in the
long-term future look the question is
what should mathematics be
what is the long-term what is the you
know right now there are three or four
million theorems that have been written
down in the history of mathematics
history of human mathematics
there is a a vast network of all
possible theorems those are the ones we
have chosen we've decided are
interesting enough that we're going to
write down put in papers or books or
whatever else
what does the infinite future of
mathematics look like as we expand on
the theorems that we already thought
were interesting build new you know go
out into this sort of mathematical
spacable possible theorems and decide
what we should populate and I I wrote
this book recently about mathematics and
have a bunch of pictures and so on about
sort of empirical mathematics looking at
what parts of mathematical space have
people populated and there's this sort
of question of as we just like we go
explore the solar system or something we
send out spacecraft we are exploring
meta mathematical space as we do
mathematics as we extend mathematics and
there's a question of sort of which
direction do we choose to go in um uh in
exploring mathematical space and I think
um
that's uh uh what we what we see
happening is that there are these kind
of towers of mathematical development
these kind of directions that one's
going in and once one's gone a certain
distance in that direction one has kind
of built up a certain set of technology
and abstraction and so on and then
there's there's further to go in that
direction but there are sort of prongs
developing a mathematical space there
are limitations to do with what we
humans are capable of of sort of
understanding as opposed to just saying
go computer go prove every theorem we
can do that but most of those theorems
will not be ones that we humans have
much to say about or have some sort of
intrinsic understanding of so I think
the um uh
it's some uh in terms of
so you know there's the mathematics that
we choose to study in pure mathematics
as a matter of uh
uh what sort of Direction what is the
aesthetic human Direction that's being
created
and there's also kind of well there's
then the question of well this
formalization which is one of the
concepts of mathematics how do we apply
that throughout things in the world I
think computational language is the
answer to that I think that is the
generalization of mathematics that gets
to be an application a way that you can
apply formalization to sort of
everything in the world now if you ask
about what Will mathematics look like in
the future
one of the things that the study of
mathematical space gives one is some
sense of what the bulk theory of
mathematics looks like instead of
through a four million theorems let's
say we have a trillion theorems what's
mathematics going to look like when
mathematicians you know it's been a few
million people so far they've worked on
mathematics in the history of human
civilization let's say there's lots more
and there are trillion theorems that
have been written down in the papers of
the future What will what will that
structure look like
here's one very important thing I think
I think matter of mathematical space in
some sense homogeneous
so in physical space you know our planet
has certain features and so on and so on
and so on but the fact is we expect that
if we were to Tool off in a spacecraft
to some other part of the universe
the the nature of the universe there
will be very similar the laws of physics
will be the same many of the things we
would observe as observers like us would
be the same
Etc so now the question is as we go
around meta mathematical space how
similar is it so for example we might go
from geometry to algebra those are two
different points in mathematical space
the theorems of algebra the theorems of
geometry they're just these little
regions of mathematical space But the
thing that's interesting is that I'm
pretty sure that there's a certain
homogeneity a matter mathematical space
and that in a sense the structure of
algebra and the structure of geometry
are unsurprisingly similar and that in a
sense any human constructed any human
observed area of mathematics will have
certain commonality which means that
there will be these giant dualities
between different areas of mathematics
these giant correspondences where we get
to to move stuff from you know from
algebra to Geometry or whatever else it
is and across different areas and things
like the langlands program which you
know attempt to do that for specific
kinds of areas of mathematics but my
feeling is one of the big big stories of
the future of mathematics will be the
the one that instead of all these
different prongs of oh I'm doing
algebraic number Theory I'm doing uh
representation Theory whatever else
there will be more and more kind of
commonalities seen between these
different areas it's kind of a little
bit like what's happened in computation
where there was a time not for very long
actually when there were Turing machines
and Lambda calculus and recursive
functions and and so on and these were
all different prongs which could have
all had their own in a sense branch of
theory of computation branch of
mathematical logic developed for them
but what became clear in the 1930s and
Beyond was that actually these are all
fundamentally equivalent they're all
Universal computers so there's some kind
of uniform thing that can say be said
about all of them I think that same
thing will happen in mathematics I think
that the the kind of the prong of
algebraic number theory is kind of like
the prong of Lambda calculus and it will
be mergable with these other prongs and
there will be these kinds of ways to
leverage sort of the big success in one
area in another area so it's similar to
the fact that we can use the success of
our physics project and use the fact
that it shows that the underlying
formalism between physics and let's say
matter mathematics is the same and so
that means that if we can say things
about you know Singularity theorems and
event Horizons and physics we can import
those results into metamatics and that's
kind of a um uh
um
that that's that's that's a
um I think an important direction for
for mathematics going into the future
um
let's see Memes comments I think World
of Warcraft they say may have helped me
understand calculus better you have a
goal with a particular group set up what
is the optimal scenario for victory
given one's resources you know this is
where I am such a naive I I you know I
have never played World of Warcraft I'm
sorry I've I'm I think I've seen it
being played but that's about as close
as I've got so it is an interesting
question to what extent one could
develop intuition for physics is other
than our own by playing video games and
so on I don't know to what extent people
have really for example even a very
simple thing which I've often thought
should be done is the relativistic video
game of uh you know you're zipping
around at close to the speed of light
what do things look like we know that
perfectly well you know the the you know
you're going down a road and you're
going close to the speed of light okay
the street lights all sort of Bend in
words uh things that you're going
towards turn blue things are going away
from turn red kind of you know things
like uh things you know get compressed
in a particular direction uh strangely
enough things like cubes will tend to
rotate because the time it takes light
to get from one slide to the other
starts mattering as you as you get
closer during the time that sort of the
light is going from one part of the cube
to an another and so on so even getting
I mean I don't have intuition for this
what it really would be like to live in
one's everyday world so to speak at
relativistic speeds
um going close to the speed of light if
I were kind of zipping around uh you
know if I you know I'm I'm going to go
to some event this evening and if I
could zip there at close to the speed of
light you know what would what would the
streets of um uh of of of Cambridge
Massachusetts or something look like
close to the speed of light I don't know
um I mean it will be interesting to get
that intuition and maybe it would help
me even in understanding things about
physics to get that in fact right now
we're making some some videos about a
physics project and it's it's beginning
to be it's sort of interesting what one
can you know kind of the intuition that
one begins to get from kind of seeing
these things in action but but yeah I
think I think I'm I'm curious I mean as
a matter of fact one kind of um game
that somebody should make is you know I
wrote this thing recently about kind of
the rule space of generative AIS you
know kind of that was uh uh you
telegenerative AI sort of make a picture
of a cat in a party hat it has a certain
place in its kind of concept space that
corresponds to that you move away from
that into kind of inter-concept space
you have all these different images that
get generated it's kind of like getting
intuition what would it be like to kind
of drive a rule spacecraft around that
space of possible Concepts an
inter-concept space and you know what is
it like I don't know it's uh that's
something it's it's kind of from a very
practical point of view just takes a
while for a GPU to generate a picture
using the modern generative Ai and so
you know the the navigating your
spacecraft in real time of the joystick
type thing is not quite as exciting as
it will one day be because it's still
quite slow but to me it's kind of an
interesting so if anybody wants to go
out and build such a such a video game
um let me know I've got ideas about it
let's see maybe a couple more things
here and then I need to
run away here
um
let's see
Allah asks
which area of tech is advancing the
fastest will this change in the future
it always changes at any given time you
know I think I've talked about this
before I mean I think there's a sort of
a a pattern of History which is new
methodology is invented
opens up a bunch of possibilities
five to ten to maybe a few more years
lots of low-hanging fruit to be picked
very rapid advance
then a hundred years of grinding to get
to the next moment of methodological
expansion
and so you know we see that in large
language models a methodological idea a
surprise that it worked there's low
hanging fruit it will get picked for a
short while it's rapidly changing right
now but that will slow down and then
there'll be a long slow grind and you
know you see that everywhere
so you know knowing what the hot new
thing is
is often challenging and it is often the
result of very practical technological
stuff sometimes it's the result of ideas
sometimes it's the result of the bizarre
phenomenon of the sudden acceptance of
ideas like people invented something and
nobody cared and then 25 50 years later
people say wow that thing is really cool
you know we're really going to go in
that direction
and you know it really wasn't a
a kind of a major conceptual Advance it
was just people decided it was
interesting now I mean that happened or
with number theory in the in probably
the mid middle part of the 20th century
people have been like who cares and then
it's like oh this is really exciting now
maybe to some extent that was because
there was sort of a a clustering of
results that were being got in that area
but it was more of a sociological
phenomenon I would say that what
particular one I'm not I'm not as as I
haven't really thought through the
history as clearly as perhaps I might
but but there are lots of places where
it's kind of like people you know
suddenly it's kind of like everybody
they're even things I've invented where
they went for decades with people like
oh who knows who cares and then suddenly
the world discovers them and everybody
thinks they're really cool and it's like
well why didn't you know that you know I
I already said that 25 years earlier you
know why weren't you paying attention
type thing but it's just not the way
things work there's this sort of
gathering social momentum that happened
around things and I think so you know
when you say what's what's new what's
coming Etc it's a um uh that's
that's code at any given time there's
always new stuff happening
you know when you see the very first
murmurings of new stuff
to the time when it's in full bloom
maybe five years
maybe 10. I'm not sure
you know then there's this period where
it's in Rapid growth and then it slows
down
and
you know if we say what are their
murmurings about I I have to say I mean
all the stuff around our physics project
and its consequences that to me is a
pretty seismic piece of murmuring I mean
it's really obvious that there's just a
huge amount of stuff that becomes
possible there and we are just beginning
to see what's possible I mean we made a
bunch of progress some people understand
that progress more people understand it
every month
um it's uh uh but but it's it's you know
it's it's it's a big very fertile thing
that is going to have high growth
um you know when it really does its its
most energetic you know in physics for
example one of the things that I think
is was a sign of a not so totally
healthy field way back was there used to
be these kind of fads in physics
everybody would say oh this is exciting
now you know this kind of new type of
string theory or this type of gauge
Theory or whatever else it was and some
fraction of the physics Community would
rush in into that fad for six months a
year maybe more and I think people even
started plotting back when I was doing
physics for a living people were
plotting the the fraction of physicists
who went into each fad versus the length
of the fad and it was getting to be a
larger fraction of all physicists a
shorter time and I don't think that was
terribly healthy in the field I think
there was kind of a death throws type
thing for the paradigms that existed at
that time but the uh uh you know that
that's a thing where finding the murmurs
that will then turn into something big
that's an interesting thing and
sometimes sometimes they're hiding in
plain sight I mean like it could be the
case that augmented reality will
suddenly take off after it's been not
taking off for uh 30 40 years
um and suddenly that will uh kind of um
uh really develop
let's see
well
um
we should totally wrap up here I think
I'm being told I am
uh maybe one more if there's something
quick he says
crucial flow asks will you ever invent a
new language again
me personally
you know
it's been interesting I I built my first
computer language starting in 1979 think
of lesson p
a lot of interesting ideas I was just in
fact I think I'm just writing probably
posts today uh reflects back to a bunch
of things that I did in SMP where I
almost figured out some things which I
think I now can actually figure out
SMP was very interesting and had uh
things that were not as easy to use as
they could have been
in building mathematical and more from
language I kind of got the opportunity
to do that again
so that was kind of that was 1986 to 88
to now that whole process of building
more and more and more on that stack
the stack is done very very well the
idea of symbolic programming the kind of
design methodologies and so on in a
sense I had it easy because I had
already kind of got to do a trial run
with SMP before and so it was easier to
not make mistakes but that that stack
has been quite wonderful to build on for
the last 36 years
but you know I did a different thing in
the early 2000s decided we're going to
build a wolf from Alpha and wolfen Alpha
is going to be something that has a very
different design methodology
it's going to take natural language
input it's going to have no
documentation it's going to have no
Precision it's just going to be
something where the user says what the
user feels like saying and it's up to us
to kind of untangle that
just like in a sense for open language
it's up to us to go compute we're not
we're not asking the user to go tell us
how to do things like you would in some
low-level language you're you know
you're just saying what you want to have
happen and it's up to us to get well
from language to actually do that
so now you ask will I ever do such a
thing again well there is something with
such a project that's quite active right
now a building what I call symbolic
discourse language it may change its
name which is kind of a symbolic
representation of the things people sort
of say every day in the world
and that design methodology is probably
going to be different from the things
I've had before so it's probably how it
exactly plugs into the Wolfram Alpha
story and the woven language story we
don't yet completely know it will
certainly attach to both of those
stories but the thing that was really
important in building wolfen Alpha was
the idea that we're going to do a
different design methodology it's not
this sort of precision precise kind of
uh formal specification structure of
awesome language it's going to be
something which is just a sort of do
what the user wants based on the yakking
that they're that they're making
and I think that's that's a piece the
whole thing we're doing with symbolic
this course language is all deeply tied
up with llms
um but in perhaps ways people might not
expect
um the uh
the thing so so yes I'm I I am planning
that and another thing that I'm
interested in I've been interested in
this for just forever is um uh kind of
programming using graphs
and is there a way of representing
things you know in a sense both from
language takes its cue from Human
natural language it's a string of
word-like things that are connected in a
sort of grammatical way
but it's not obvious and that by the way
is a very powerful thing to do because
that is sort of the the thing that plugs
into our highest levels of thinking is
human language so that's a great model
to use for computational language but
the thing that I sort of Wonder is is it
the only model and are there things that
involve graphs and sort of dementia you
know three-dimensionality and spatiality
and so on that are an alternative way to
kind of uh sort of organize one's
thoughts now people often argue you know
thinking and language are deeply
connected we don't think without
language and so on maybe that's right
um maybe we can think sort of spatially
and maybe we can think in terms of you
know graphs networks things like that I
don't know whether I can I mean I don't
know whether it's some the kind of thing
where one learns to be able to do that I
mean I've certainly done quite my uh my
Tour of Duty with with graphs and
networks for all kinds of purposes
um so so maybe I have as good a chance
as anybody to be able to do that but
it's still the question is is there a
way of expressing oneself and thinking
about things that is fundamentally sort
of uh in terms of graphs and networks
rather than in terms of something that's
essentially linguistically based I don't
know I've been wondering about that
since the early 1980s I've done a bunch
of experiments they've typically not
been successful because basically it's
like well you can do this but I don't
understand what's going on it's not
useful for me as a way to organize and
formalize my thoughts
so uh the answer is I I don't know I I
think in some sense yes invent something
but um uh whether you call it a language
will be an interesting question
all right we should uh
uh
oh boy there's a question here I almost
can't resist is there anything you've
recently changed your mind about
um but I will say one quick thing and
then we'll maybe talk about this another
time but but um you know I had no
uh you know back if you'd asked me this
time last year our language models going
to be able to write reasonable text I
would have said
no particular indication they can
they're just babbling and and writing
things which are sort of statistically
reasonable but don't make a lot of sense
uh that's something where clearly the
the aliens landed and the llms were able
to start producing very human-like
clumps of text so that was a thing that
um definitely changed my mind about
something and I have to say in our
physics project as well one big thing
was I didn't think we'd get nearly as
far as we've got I thought it'd be a
hundred years before one can get to the
place where we've got to now and I think
that it is a thing where some of the
predictions
I think there may be some some things
which turn out to be really hard and we
can't get anywhere with them and then
maybe some low-hanging fruit that's
lower hanging than I expect that allow
us to to Really uh you know make all
sorts of interesting progress all right
with that I should probably wrap up for
today uh thanks for lots of interesting
questions and comments and uh I look
forward to doing this another time
bye for now